[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN MURRAY: My
name is John Murray.
I'm a product manager
here at Google Cloud.
And I work on what used to
be called the Cloud Services
Platform.
We didn't change
the session, but we
did change the name on Tuesday.
So it's now called Anthos.
And I'm going to talk
a little bit today
about policy
management for that.
So going to go through
some of the tools
that we have in the
open source software
that we're shipping
that allows you
to manage corporate
policies, governance
policies, and those sorts
of things on top of Anthos,
as well as talk about
some of the tooling we've
built on top of that open
source to make that easier,
particularly when
you're running a hybrid
or multi-cloud environment.
We've got a lot of
distributed compute out there.
So let's get started.
For those who did not see
the announcement on Tuesday,
Anthos is our application
modernization platform
for the hybrid
multi-cloud world.
And the idea here is that we
have services, a marketplace,
and a control plane that lives
in the cloud here on GCP,
and is a central place for
you to manage all that stuff.
And that fans out to a bunch of
different compute environments
either, say, running on GCP,
running on prem with GKE
On-Prem, or other clouds.
The basis of that are a
number of building blocks.
And so it starts kind of at the
bottom with the infrastructure
operator.
So I've got that
role here as somebody
working on Google Cloud.
But that could be
infrastructure that's
in any kind of environment.
It could be another cloud.
It could be on prem.
And so that's stuff like
storage and networking, VMs,
and other primitive building
blocks of infrastructure.
That's the foundation of Anthos.
On top of that, we have a
Kubernetes distribution.
So GKE in the cloud,
GKE On-Prem, on prem.
And that allows you to
have a uniform computing
layer with a uniform API across
all of these environments.
That's kind of the first level
where policies come into play,
and where you can start
controlling that environment.
And then above that,
one of the other layers
that we have is Istio,
which is our service
mesh in open source,
but also is something
that we manage on GKE, and that
we're building tooling around,
such as the cloud services mesh,
which is in alpha right now.
And that really allows you
to think about your services
at the HTTP L7 layer,
abstract those out,
and think about
traffic as a graph
in a microservices environment.
There's a number
of policies there
that have to do with how
services talk to one another,
how traffic is routed, and we'll
get into that in a little bit.
There are many other
pieces of Anthos
here that you can
bring to the table.
I'm going to talk
mostly about these,
but we have things like
CloudRun and Knative
for running
serverless containers.
Although the servers are still
there, as many of you know.
And things like our marketplace,
various other bits and pieces.
In addition to that and talk
today about Anthos Config
Management.
So that is a way to
knit all of this stuff
together and provide you
with a single administrative
experience for talking to
all these different platforms
in a distributed environment.
And the way that
that works is that we
use the Kubernetes native policy
formats, which effectively
are putting all of
those policies in code
so that you can analyze them
so that they're repeatable,
and so that the policies that
you apply to this environment
are auditable,
reproducible, transactional,
and self-healing.
What I mean by that is, if
you put all of this stuff
in a Git repository,
you get a lot
of the advantages
of source control.
So you can go and look at
everything in one place.
The changes that you make
to a particular cluster
or the multi-cluster
environment are
reproducible across new
clusters that you bring in
or new service meshes
that you bring in.
A Git repository
is transactional
so that when you make a
commit, you can roll that back.
You can roll it forward.
You know exactly what was
changed by when and by whom.
And then the
self-healing aspects
of this or that we are looking
at these Git repositories,
bringing down the configuration
to all these different places,
and then constantly reconciling
that in the local environments
to make sure that if
things drift out of line,
that we bring them back in.
And I'll talk a little
bit more about that.
So let's talk about the policies
that are available to you.
The idea with Anthos
is for us mainly
to work off of open source.
So there's a lot of
open source stuff
that you can do on
these platforms, as well
as a lot of stuff that we can
do inside the infrastructure.
So to the degree that we've
needed our customers to operate
on these platforms, we've gone
into the upstream open source
and tried to contribute
to some of these things
alongside many other folks
who work on the platforms.
For Kubernetes, that means
things like access control.
So Kubernetes has a role-based
access control system
that allows you to define who's
allowed to do what on any given
cluster, who can deploy
pods, who can make changes
to policies.
Networking.
There is a number of different
networking mechanisms in there.
Things like network
policy, which
allow you to define routing
between individual pods
on a cluster.
We support that in
GKE as well as on prem
now with our partners
at Tigera, who
make the container networking
interface for Calico.
And then security and isolation.
So you can do things like
set up a pod security
policy in Kubernetes that
allows you to define what
a container is allowed to
do in terms of interacting
with the host environment.
And that creates isolation
through things like namespaces,
as well as isolating the
containers from the underlying
environment to ensure that they
only have the access that they
need, and they're not
able to break out of that
and move across boundaries.
On the Istio side, one
of the great policies
there is traffic routing.
So Istio is something
that you can
use to think about your
services and the level
of the inbound traffic that
you have, and set up a gateway,
and bring in your
ingress traffic.
And then route that
to microservices
using things like waiting.
Setting up things
like mutual TLS
so that all of the
different services
within your service
mesh are communicating
in an encrypted fashion.
You can do things like
service-to-service access
control.
And so if you have
a flat network
where everything is
talking to one another,
that might be fine.
But it might mean
that an attacker can
compromise one of your
services and go look
at something that they're
not supposed to be.
So service-to-service
access control
is a way to ensure
that only services that
should be talking
to other services
are sending traffic around.
And then there's a whole bunch
of extensibility in Istio.
So there's a Mixer
component in there
that allows people
to bring in plug-ins.
And so you can do things
like plug-in telemetry,
but you can also do things
like plug-in authorization.
And there's a number
of different things
in the community that
we support there.
And then when we talk
about the infrastructure,
we're really talking about
the underlying stuff.
So on GCP, that's stuff
like GCP services.
So you may have your
clusters backed by storage
is sitting on a GCS bucket.
Or you may have your services
backed by a SQL database,
like Cloud SQL.
Things like firewalls, secure
images, and even the cluster
flags that are on your cluster.
And so we want all of this stuff
to be able to be declarative.
And what I mean
by that is you can
show up and tell
us exactly how you
want this environment to look.
You can put
constraints around that
to say these are
the types of things
that we want our developers
or our administrators
to be able to do.
And then enforce
all of that in code,
just like you enforce things
when you build applications.
And so shift some of that
compliance further up
into the infrastructure
pipeline,
and then give you
the tooling to make
that a lot easier to manage.
So I talked a little bit
about API server flags.
That's a really important piece
of security on Kubernetes.
There's a lot of things
that you can set up
a cluster to do that
are relatively insecure.
And so it's not sufficient
just to come in and change
the configuration on
top of your cluster.
You often have to think
about the configuration
of the cluster itself.
One are the advantages
we have with GKE On-Prem.
and that Kubernetes distribution
is that those clusters
are built declaratively.
And so you're able to
specify a cluster actually
as a Kubernetes and object
with all of those flag set.
And so you have a reproducible
way of stamping out
clusters that's secure.
And you can validate that
by looking at the code.
Access control I
mentioned already.
RBAC is, I think, the
best and most widely used
way of managing
that on Kubernetes,
but there are a
number of other ways
you can manage access control.
Network policy I mentioned.
Resource quota Is
a way to set up
policies about who can do
what in terms of resource
consumption so CPU, memory,
number of processes running,
that sort of thing.
And that's a great tool if you
have multi-tenant environments.
We've got a lot of people
sharing one cluster.
You don't want noisy neighbors.
You want to keep people
isolated and ensure
that they're only using
the resources that
are allocated to them.
Admission control I'll talk a
little bit about later as well,
but that's a point of
extensibility within Kubernetes
that allows you to look at
the inbound traffic on the API
server and enact custom
rules against it.
So you can do things like
bring your business rules in.
If they're not handled by
some of these other built-in
policies, then you can
enforce them yourself.
And finally, pod
security policies,
which allows you to define
what things are allowed to do
vis-a-vis the host system.
And there's a number of
levers and dials there.
For Istio, the
policies are really
about defining what
you can do in terms
of service-to-service routing.
So Istio-- what it does
is injects an Envoy proxy
as a sidecar to all of your
services that are running.
And then it uses
that mesh of proxies
to enforce policies, as
well as collect telemetry.
And so there's a
number of adapters,
as I said there, that allow
you to do things like push
your telemetry out to
Prometheus and Grafana,
or Stackdriver on Google Cloud.
And then you can do
other things like connect
with the Apigee APIs over
GRPC and enforce policy there.
And those sidecars also are able
to pick up policies directly
from the clusters which
Istio is running on.
So you can do things
like enforce mutual TLS,
which is a great thing to do.
Means that if somebody is in
and able to sniff your traffic,
it's all encrypted.
Service-to-service
authorization allows
you to do routing and rollouts.
And so you can
shape your traffic.
You can move it.
You can do blue-green
deployments,
all through a top
level set of rules.
And then you've got
fine-grained GRPC controls
if you're doing GRPCs in
between your services.
So infrastructure.
There's a number
of interesting ways
you can provision your
infrastructure as code.
I mentioned GKE On-Prem.
Those clusters,
including the CIDR ranges
that they have on prem, the
API flags that you're setting,
that's all declarative.
So you can specify that once.
You can stamp out clusters
that are all doing things
according to what you'd like.
It is not a scenario
where you have
to have somebody running
a command line tool
and having multiple developers
doing whatever they want.
As an administrator,
it's something
you can keep control of.
And that GKE On-Prem
API as well is
able to control the
underlying machines
and so it kind of
abstracts away that the VMs
and allows you to do
things like rolling
updates of the infrastructure.
So you can do a node
upgrade, scale a cluster, all
through a code interface.
We're taking some of
that declarative stuff
and bringing it to GCP as well
in a Kubernetes environment.
So we have a number of GKE
customers who need to use
the underlying storage
resources-- for example,
on GCP--
from their Kubernetes cluster.
Today, if you've got something
that's backed by a GCP service,
you've got to go
outside of Kubernetes
and go into the GCP APIs
to do the provisioning
of that infrastructure.
We've announced a
GCP Cloud Connector
in alpha, which is a way
for you to do that directly
from the Kubernetes API.
So that doesn't have full
coverage of our API service
today.
But what it does allow you to do
is manage some of the resources
I've got listed here so that
you can create those things
as Kubernetes objects.
So when you're doing a
deployment of an application
that's backed by,
say, Cloud Spanner,
you can come in and not only
do the deployment directly
against the Kubernetes
API, but you can say,
I also want a Spanner database
to be deployed alongside this.
And that's defined as
a Kubernetes resource.
We use what's called custom
resource definitions, which
is extensibility built
into the Kubernetes API.
And that allows you to define
these things at that layer.
And so if you're coming into
Anthos and you want to do that,
you can manage all of that as
a set of Kubernetes resources.
So that's kind of
the set of things
you're able to do with the stuff
that's shipping with Anthos.
That doesn't necessarily
mean that it's
easy to manage a hybrid
multi-cloud setup.
So I want to talk a little
bit about dealing with scale
how you can scale up from maybe
a small footprint into having
something that runs across
a large tech organization
where you have multiple teams
of administrators, potentially.
Lots and lots of
developers, all working
in a fairly fractured
hybrid environment.
And some of the
tools we're building
to make that a little
bit easier on folks.
So this is a journey that
I see a lot of people
go through when they
start with Kubernetes
and they start GKE, is that when
you're evaluating something,
you've got one operator, one set
of policies, and one cluster.
That's step one.
And it's fairly easy then to
just take your policy side
and run a command line tool like
Kubectl that pushes policies
to the cluster.
And you can keep those
on your local hard drive.
And because it's you and your
cluster, everything's fine.
You understand everything
that's going on.
You're the only person
who has to care.
But quickly it gets a
little bit more complicated.
When you bring in a
team of operators,
when you have
multiple people who
are responsible for managing
a Kubernetes environment,
you can't just have
a local set of files.
And you can't just have people
pushing them, necessarily,
from their command
line, because you
can step on each other's toes.
One person might be writing
over somebody else's stuff.
And so that's where we
think a repository is
a really useful tool.
Source control mechanisms
were built specifically
for this use case, where people
need to collaborate on code.
And you can do things
like use the tooling
that's built around
them to do code reviews,
to do static analysis
of that code,
and to understand who did what
when to roll those things back,
et cetera.
So there's been decades
of work on repositories.
That's a solved problem
for collaborating on code,
and we want to use that
for infrastructure as well.
But it gets even
more complicated
when you have these sort of
multi-platform environments.
So if you're running on
GCP, you're running on prem,
you're running in
another cloud, now you
have to deal not only
with collaborating
with a bunch of people
in a repository.
You have to deal with
getting that repository
and its declarations out
to all those clusters
so that the policies that you've
written are actually applied.
And that's a
non-trivial problem.
You can loop through these
things and push the policies.
But if that fails, you're
halfway through that.
And now you've got
one set of policies
in one place, another set
of policies in another.
These are distributed
environments.
So people can come in
locally and make changes.
Even if you do your best
to keep them out of that
and keep them
through this channel,
it's always possible for
something to go down,
something accidental to happen.
So if you're not aware
of that, or you're not
able to reconcile that,
you may have something
that's out of scope
or out of policy,
and you don't even
know about it.
So dealing with the
collaboration aspects
and the distribution
aspects is something
that we wanted to build tooling
around to help folks out.
I'll quickly talk
about why you might
want to have a bunch of
different clusters, why you
might end up in this scenario.
There are a ton of
reasons, and they often
tend to be driven by the
nature of your business
or the vertical that you're in.
These are some of the
things that we see.
So obviously, everybody who's
been operating for a while
has legacy software.
Might have an ERP system.
You might have a
Catalog Database
that's sitting on prem.
But you want to do
stuff in the cloud,
so you're building your
new site in the cloud.
You've got to have compute
in both environments
because the data gravity or
things that just don't make
sense to lift and shift over.
You may want local execution.
So it's not always possible
to do everything in the cloud,
and particularly if you're
dealing with tons of data.
If you've got a factory
floor or a warehouse
with IoT stuff running
around, you probably
don't want to ship up every
little last bit of data
up into the cloud.
And you might want
compute running locally.
Jurisdictional issues.
So if you're a global
operator, you're
going to have the
need to deal with laws
all over the place that have
to deal with data sovereignty.
Keeping things that are
generated in one place
stored in that place.
Augmenting services.
You may have a bunch of
stuff that's running on prem,
but you want to take
advantage of some
of the great machine
learning tools
that they have in the cloud.
And so you've got to
get data up there.
IoT.
We're running into a
number of retailers
who run Kubernetes clusters
in every store from things
like point of sale systems or
telemetry from various sensors,
and then bursting.
So you've got things
running on prem,
but you want to be able to
have flexible capacity using
the cloud.
So you may have some--
you may have all of
these things driving you.
And where that leads
you is that you end up
with a fairly
fractured environment,
and you need some kind of glue
to bring it back together.
Not only that, but you've
got to deal with compliance.
So you've got an environment
that's growing in complexity.
And then you've got
an outside environment
that has ever-increasing
concerns about governance.
So that's things like the
alphabet soup of compliance.
The GDPRs, and the
HIPAAs, and the SOX.
It's things like
government regulations.
It's also things like business
processes and security needs.
Those are getting more and more
in terms of the number of them.
They are getting
more complicated.
And the complexity
of your environment
is just making that worse
and worse over time.
And so we see that, and we
think an important solution
to that is really thinking
about policy as code.
Taking the various
policies that you have
and turning them
into code so that you
can rein in a little
bit of that complexity,
and start using compute
to deal with it.
And so policy as code
is a pretty simple idea.
It's basically the
ability to take everything
that you care about
as an administrator,
codify it, and then start
running your business processes
and your business
rules on top of that.
Anthos Config
Management is a tool
designed to help with
that kind of principle.
And so we've got a
multi-cluster architecture.
It scales to
hundreds of clusters,
even thousands of clusters,
because the repository is
really the central piece of it.
And so anytime you
bring up a new cluster,
if you've got Anthos Config
Management installed on it,
it connects to the
central repository.
It can pull down the
policies that apply
to that particular cluster.
And that means that we
run fairly distributed.
And so if you have a cluster
in every retail store,
that's an environment
that we can support.
It works on prem,
and in the cloud.
There's nothing about
the service that
requires you to talk to GCP.
We are going to
build ways of pulling
in telemetry, ways of
managing it through the cloud.
But it can run entirely
disconnected on prem.
So you can keep your
repository on prem.
You can have your
clusters on prem
if you're running with Anthos.
You don't necessarily have
to talk back to the cloud
to get in touch with
your repo or pull down
your configurations.
It is declarative
and continuous.
So by declarative,
what I mean is
you put your policies
in there as you
expect them to be applied.
You don't have to wait
for them to be applied.
You just tell the
system what you want,
and that's kind of
the Kubernetes way.
And then we take
that declaration.
We apply it to all the
different API servers,
and then run in
a continuous loop
to ensure that the system is
brought in line with that.
So that reconciliation
is a constant process.
And what it allows you
to do is define once
how things should be,
and then hand that off
to the controllers that are
running in the various clusters
to ensure that things
are happening that way.
And then migrating to
it is fairly simple
because we are using the
same format for these policy
definitions as Kubernetes.
It is an open format.
It's the format that people
are used to managing clusters.
If you're managing
clusters today
or you're managing
Istio today, you
can take your configurations,
cut and paste them in,
and it should work.
How that looks is that we just
use Git as a source of truth.
And so our repository is more
or less a set of YAML files
that are expressing
all of your policies
with a little bit of
massaging to ensure
that the policies that need
to go to one place or another
are handled.
And so it handles all your
Kubernetes and Istio resources,
integrates with
your source control.
Everything is native YAML.
And we can plug our validators
into whatever source control
system you're using and run
inside the same workflow
that you have for your code.
It's all meant to be
plugable and extensible.
So you can see on the right
here I've got a directory
structure of a repository.
I'm putting all of my
stuff in namespaces.
I've got quota.
I've got role bindings.
And it looks very
much like a repository
you might set up for yourself
if you were just applying
these things [INAUDIBLE].
So I'll get more into that
when we go into the demo.
But that's the basic
structure of it.
So how that looks inside
of a sample architecture
for a hybrid Anthos
deployment is
that you might have a policy
repository that's sitting
in an on-prem data center.
And you can put all of
your Kubernetes definitions
that you need as an
administrator there.
So things like access control,
things like network policy,
pod security policy, et cetera.
Things like your Istio
mesh enforcing mutual TLS.
That can all go into
that policy store.
And then you may be running
clusters in the Google Cloud
Platform.
You may be running
clusters on prem.
As long as you have
interconnect setup
so that that looks like
one routable network,
everything can come back and
talk to the policy repository.
And all of the
clusters that you've
got running in both
environments are
able to see those and
pull their stuff down.
If that interconnect goes
down, we keep the last state.
We continue to enforce
those policies.
And so any network interruption
between those environments
just means that new changes
aren't able to come across.
But the last good
state is still there,
and is still being enforced.
And you can see we have
our config management
operator in both places.
That's the distributed
system that's
running on those
clusters and making sure
that everything is in line.
And the fact that it
is a distributed system
means that, again, if
there's a networking outage,
those processes
are still running.
And so what this
enables you to do
is have defense in
depth for the policies
that you really care about.
And it's really a shift
left sort of mentality
for administrative policies.
So the flow here
when you're making
changes, once you have stuff
stored in a Git repository,
is that anything you want to
do, you cut a branch for it.
And that's humans
cutting a branch.
So say you've got
an administrator who
wants to add a new namespace
for a development team.
Cut a branch, add that there,
do a code review on it,
and push it down.
But you can also have
machine processes, algorithms
that are doing the same thing.
So if we can do static analysis
on all of your policies,
we can make recommendations.
One of the things
we announced here
is our policy intelligence
stuff that we're
doing on Google Cloud
that's doing analysis of IM
to look at things
like overgranting.
Once we're able to
see those things,
we can translate them
back into changes.
If we know your
current state and code,
we know how we
think it should be,
we can send you a pull request.
And so there's a
whole set of stuff
that you can do once you're
able to do static analysis
on your policies.
We're just getting
started in that area.
But I think it's a
really promising avenue
once we can get folks to
start doing stuff in code.
Once you've got those changes,
you can validate them.
And so you can put all
of your business rules--
at least those business rules
that you're able to codify--
into validation.
So we ship with
validation that looks
at syntax and the
correctness of the repository
to ensure that bad
configs, malformed configs,
are not coming down.
But as we continue to
develop on top of this,
we're going to
ship more and more
validation to allow you
to do things like bring
plugable business roles.
And what that means
is that if somebody
is in violation of your
corporate policies,
or they're doing something
that they shouldn't be doing
in terms of changing
network routing or changing
access controls, you can
catch that in the pipeline
before it hits your
environment, before it goes out
to your clusters.
And so you can
shift from grabbing
those things in auditing every
so often to understanding
that this is a bad
config upfront,
and we're not going to
allow you to push that.
Because we're running, say, a
GitHub check on it that lets
us know that this policy's
outside of the guardrails
that the administrators
have set for it.
That's going through
code review as well.
So teams of administrators
now can collaborate.
You can have two
people who have to turn
the key on major policies.
You can see who reviewed it.
You can make changes.
You can do all of that
before it hits the production
environment.
And then you can also enforce
things at the deployment stage.
So admission control to block
things from the clusters.
You can use the same logic
invalidation against the API.
So even if something comes
through this process,
you can stop it from
hitting the API,
and stop us from syncing it.
Reconciliation
and auditing still
allow you to guard against
drift on those clusters.
So if somebody comes in and
makes a local change that's
out of spec, you can come in
and overwrite that immediately.
I said I'd talk about
admission control here.
So another project that we're
working on in open source
is called Gatekeeper.
Gatekeeper is an
admission controller
that we're planning on
including and helping
folks manage in concert
with a lot of this stuff.
The key thing about Gatekeeper
as an admission controller
is that it uses the Open Policy
Agent, which is a CNCF project.
And Open Policy Agent is
effectively a policy evaluation
engine.
It takes a set of policies
expressed in code that anybody
can write, and will enforce
them wherever it goes.
So what Gatekeeper does is
wrap that in the infrastructure
it needs to be run as
an admission controller.
And it allows you to define
as a Kubernetes resource
any policy you want
to be evaluated
against things that are
going to hit the API server.
So an example of that
might be label enforcement
on deployments.
If you need all of
your deployments
to have particular labels, or
you need them to have a label,
you can say, look, if
you're going to deploy,
and you're going to
deploy this kind of image,
it needs to have this
particular label,
or we're not going to accept it.
And those label rules
may be specific to you,
and you can program
them in there.
So Gatekeeper comes with
a Kubernetes interface
to push standard
rules, but it also
has a programming
language that allows
you to write those yourself.
So let's jump into a demo here.
I'll show you a little
bit about how we run.
Just give me a second
to log into my machine.
OK, can we bring up the demo?
So what I'm going
to do here is show
you just a simple deployment
of an Istio application.
It's called the
Bookinfo application.
It's the kind of
demo-- it's the thing
you may have seen in a few
places on the floor here.
It's available in the
Istio docs as an example.
I'm just going to play around
with some of the policies
here to show you what that
looks like in a code repository,
make a couple of changes, and
we'll go look at that live.
So what I have here is a
Tmux session on the left
is where I'm going to be
running all my commands.
It's all scripted, but
it's all running live.
On the right, I've got
my local file system.
So I have a copy of
a repository that I'm
hosting up in GitHub there.
And at the bottom, I've
got a couple of watches.
And those watches are on
live clusters running on GKE.
I'm running on two, but
everything I'm doing here you
could run on thousands of
clusters if you wanted to.
We've got a watch here,
just looking at some pods.
So you'll be able to
see them coming up
as I'm making changes
in the repository.
So I'm going to set
my Kubectl to look
at a particular cluster.
And I'm going to bring
in all of the policies
that I need for my application.
So this is the local
file system here.
This is our repository format
for CSP config management--
sorry, Anthos config management.
We've got cluster scoped
resources at the top.
So I've got a pod
security policy in there
that's ensuring that
my deployments are only
able to do certain things
against the host environment.
I've got a cluster role there
for service deployers that
allows me to define on a
namespace per namespace level
who should be allowed to
deploy within that namespace.
So that's something
I can hand out
to individual groups of
users or individual users.
And then I have all my
namespace level resources.
So this is where all of the
deployments are defined.
I've got two namespaces here--
miscellaneous and services.
And then I have an admin
role binding that I want
to apply across both of them.
And you notice that
admin role binding
sits in the directory structure
above both of those namespaces.
What we allow in our
repository format
is kind of copy
down inheritance.
So if you have a
resource that you
want to be spread across
multiple namespaces,
we can use the hierarchy
of the directory structure
to inherit that down.
We can also apply it to
a group of namespaces.
So if you don't have
a hierarchy and you
want to just use sets of
namespaces to apply policies,
we have a mechanism for that.
In addition, you can apply
policies to individual clusters
or individual sets of clusters
based on label selection.
So this allows you to say,
OK, I have one set of policies
that need to be everywhere.
Or have some policies
that just need
to be in these
namespaces, or just
these clusters, or some
combination thereof.
I've got all my services
for the Bookinfo app
here in the services namespace.
And then I've got a
miscellaneous namespace
up there that just has
a namespace definition
and a quota attached
to it right now.
So it's empty.
There's nothing running there.
So let's go look at
what we've got here.
So I'm going to add
this to my repository.
You see nothing's
running at the moment.
This is all local.
It's just a set of
policies in my file system.
I'm going to make a commit
up to my Git repository,
and add all of these
files, and push that live.
So this is going up to GitHub,
pushing all of those policies
there and updating
the repository.
And then I've got the
clusters watching that.
And you can see
already I've got pods
initializing on cluster two.
Cluster one's a little bit
behind, but it's catching up.
And so now I've got
all of the services
that I need for my microservices
application to run.
I can go take a
look at the cluster.
So I'm going to go look
at the role bindings
in the miscellaneous namespace.
So as you can see, there's no
role binding applied directly
to that namespace.
All it's getting is
an inherited role
binding from the
directory above it.
But if you look at it
live in the cluster,
there's that admin role binding
that showed up 35 seconds ago.
And so this is great for
things like administrative role
bindings, this inheritance.
And then you can set that once
and apply it and make sure
that every single one
of your namespaces
in a multi-tenant cluster has
access for your administrators.
It's not just for role binding,
so you can also do things
like apply a network policy.
So if you have the requirement
that you want everybody
to be strictly defining
pod-to-pod traffic,
so you say this
service is only allowed
to talk to that service, you
could put an empty network
policy at the root
of your repository
and have it inherited down
to all of your namespaces.
What that will do
is, by default,
cut off all traffic
outside of the namespace.
And it will force
your developers
to come in and define it
explicitly on top of that.
So it's different
ways that you can
use that to simplify
your policy application,
not have to be
repetitive and doing
things namespace by namespace.
One of the other
nice things we do
is guard against people coming
in and doing destructive things
against administrative policies.
So that's in admin role binding.
If I'm an administrator, I
probably want that there.
I need to be able
to get in there.
If somebody came in
and decided that they
were going to delete
my SRE admin role
binding from their namespace so
they could lock out the admins,
that would be bad.
I've got administrative
access on this cluster,
so I can go do that.
So let's go do
something destructive.
Let's delete that role binding.
So now my SREs
can't get back in.
But if we go look at it on the
cluster, you can see it's back.
Seven seconds ago, which is
just about when I applied it,
we came back in and rewrote it.
And so if you come
in and you try
to affect one of these policies
that the administrator has
applied, we can
automatically reconcile
that back to whatever's
in the repository.
So let's go look at the quota
in the miscellaneous namespace.
So this is resource quota
that I'm applying here.
So in this namespace,
I put in a policy that
says you can only have one pod.
You can only use 10%
of a virtual CPU.
It only gets 100 megs of memory.
If I want to say,
deploy a pod here,
I can do that as long as
I'm within that quota.
I'm going to deploy--
it's kind of cut off
on the left there,
but it is a instance,
a BusyBox that sleeps.
This is not a
particularly useful thing
to deploy in your clusters,
but just for an example.
You can notice, if you
see just at the top there,
I'm deploying a pod, but I
happen to have misspelled it.
It says Pd instead of
Pod up on the left.
So this won't work if I try
to push it to the cluster.
If I put it in the repository,
it'll never get synced down.
I'm just writing it locally.
So that's not a problem yet.
As I said, one of the things
we ship with is a validation.
So we have a command
line tool called Nomos.
This can run is a Git hook.
It can run as a check, say,
in GitHub or some other source
tooling system so that every
time you push something
into the repository,
you can validate
that it's syntactically
correct, that it's correct
based on the format
of the repository,
and that you're not going to
be trying to push bad configs.
If I run that against this pod
definition, it throws an error.
It lets me know no matches
for Kind Pd in version v1.
So let's go fix that.
I'm going to come in here
and add my missing o,
and then save it.
And so if I run that
validation again,
it passes clean with no errors.
So now I'm ready to go.
And that's a clean pod.
So let's go take a look at
the running services here.
I'm going to figure out
where my service is actually
running here by looking
at the gateway to Istio.
I'm going to pick this up,
and we can go look at it.
You see this is the
GitHub repository where
I'm running right now.
If I refresh that, you can
see all of the resources
that I've got here.
So let's go look at
our Istio service.
Doesn't look like it's running.
Seems like I've got a
networking problem here.
Try one more thing.
So it looks like my
pods are running,
but it is not routable.
Not sure if that's my local
networking causing problems
or not.
All right, well, we'll move on.
We've got running pods.
We've got no network
connectivity.
So one of the things
I can do with this
is change some of the routing
rules in my microservices mesh.
So the Istio allows
you to define
what we call virtual services.
Virtual services
can take traffic
that's coming in
through the gateway
and route it into
individual pods.
I've got virtual services
defined here for various things
that are running in my
microservices architecture.
And if you look, you can see
I've got a review service here
that's routing
100% of my traffic
to the v1 pod of reviews.
There are actually
three different versions
of reviews running on
each of these clusters.
So if I want, I can
do an upgrade in place
by routing the
traffic from v1 to v2,
because those are running.
Now, in a real life
environment, I probably
would do this very slowly.
I would take it
and I would maybe
have a canary branch
write a cluster that
was pointing at a canary
branch of my policies.
Make that change in
the canary branch.
Go take a look at it live.
Make sure it was working.
I may decide to route just
a very small percentage
of traffic there, go
look at my monitoring,
and make sure that
that was working.
You can do all of that
directly through this kind
of code-based interface.
But since we're
short on time, let's
just do it live in production.
So I'm going to
upgrade this to v2.
And I'm going to save it.
And that's all I need to
do to upgrade that service.
Now, what that
does is it changes
to a new version of reviews
that actually calls the ratings
system.
So it's going to bring
in additional information
to the Bookinfo app.
And we can make that
change and push it up.
OK.
So that's gone out to GitHub.
And now if we look
at the live cluster,
it's still looking at v1,
but it just flipped over.
So you can see where it
says subset down there.
Now it's pointing at v2.
So we've changed
our routing rules
live on all of our clusters.
If I go look at
this other cluster,
hopefully my service
came up there.
So let's see that one
and see if it's live.
OK, one out of two ain't bad.
So this is my other cluster.
If you had seen it before when
it was working on cluster 1,
you would have seen that
there were no star ratings.
There are star ratings
now because I've
upgraded that version
of the microservice.
And it is pulling from
the rating service
because of the routing
rules I've changed.
And these routing rules have
changed on both those clusters
simultaneously.
If I were to enroll 10
clusters or 20 clusters,
I could make that change
across all of them.
Or I could make that change
across a subset of them,
depending on what
I want to do there.
One other good thing about
having a Git repository
is that it's transactional.
So everything that
I've done here
was done in a particular commit.
And I can roll those
back in any time.
If I want to undo
all of my changes
and get back to a clean
state that I know is OK,
I can just delete
everything I added locally
in my environment, and then
push it back up to the cluster.
And so effectively
what that does
is reverse all of the
commits that I made,
removes all the files that
I added, and goes back
to the state that we were
at when we started the demo.
And if I push that
up, it's going
to clean everything
out that I built.
It's going to clean out
all of those routing rules.
Is going to clean
out all these pods.
It's going to restore my state
back to where I wanted it.
And if we look, we should see
those pods start to terminate.
And there they go.
And so this is going to
roll everything back,
bring it back to an entirely
clean slate where I've gotten
naked clusters.
So that is my demo.
Can you go back to
the slides, please?
So that's CSP
Config Management--
Anthos Config Management.
I'll get used to
that eventually.
If you're interested,
it's available now
to Anthos customers.
So if were a participating
in the Anthos beta
or you're signing up for Anthos,
this comes along with it.
It works on prem today.
It works in the cloud today.
If you're interested
in getting early access
because you're a
GKE customer, we
are going to make it
available to GKE customers.
And so you can sign up here
if you're interested in that.
And I'll whitelist you
for that and bring you in.
We do expect to make it
available on GKE as well
for folks who are
purely cloud based
and working with us in GCP.
We're out of time.
I'll hang out if
folks want to talk.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]